okay so I actually got this recently
this is uh it came too late for the
video but I was saying yes to everything
and this is one of the things that
showed up this is a Magic Mouse case now
just as our refresher this is Apple
we're talking about the richest
technology company in the world and this
is the mouse they ship with their
computers it's the best they could do
somehow it's terrible it somehow has two
fatal flaws one is that it's an
ergonomic nightmare for anyone who
doesn't have baby sized hands but then
two is when the battery finally dies the
charge port is at the bottom so you
can't use it while you just wait for it
to charge it's hilarious so this company
has made like a 3D printed plastic case
for it you basically just slot it in
and now it's better I mean the idea is
it's giving you an arched shape to
actually rest your hand it just turns
out now there's kind of a cliff that
your fingers hang off of and it
introduces a slightly new different type
of fatigue is kind of weird I don't know
there is a bit of a cavity up here for a
charging cable if you want to store it
in there so for an extra 40 bucks now
the mouse only has one fatal flaw
two out of ten